all right I'm back it's been a while
where do we even start right I mean it's
just been so long since I did the last
livestream I guess I should explain why
I haven't done a livestream for so long
which is basically I think I did the
last one
right before a show break and then a
million things happened at once we hired
a new full-time person we launched on a
new platform we've been doing a million
things and it's just been insane I mean
it's been so busy and we are doing so
many different things some of which I'll
tell you about that I have not been
streaming and I apologize for that I
hope to get back to it
people email almost daily saying when
are we gonna get back to the live
streams and the answer is right now the
answer is right now and I will be
talking about the Robert Moeller
subpoena of Trump Russia organization
documents I will be taking questions
will be doing super Chad's I mean I got
to catch up on everything right so we're
gonna be talking about a lot of
different things hi to everybody in the
chat people already talking about the
new David Pakman show coffee mugs which
are going over pretty damn well I must
say so we're gonna get to a lot of
different things couple different things
one thing that I think you will like is
that I have now set up a way where you
will be able to for example in reviewing
the robert muller article i will be able
to you'll be able to see me and i'll be
able to show you the article that's one
possibility i've also set it up if that
gets a little bit laggy with just the
article and not me so I don't know maybe
people will like that that's that's
something new and we will get to this
article and I can be down in the corner
as well but when I am in this mode you
will not be able to see all of the great
different animations that will play when
different things happen so when somebody
makes a pledge on patreon we are
supposed to be able to
are we gonna be able to do it let's see
if we can if I can show you what that
looks like and I think this is all
finally working as well I'm actually
very excited about this because a lot of
this stuff was not working well before
in the old days when somebody becomes a
patron they're supposed to be there it
is little animation and noise when
someone sends a super chat we're
supposed to see that when someone makes
a donation on stream Labs we're supposed
to see that and the new thing is and
I've talked about this only after the
last live stream we are now part of the
YouTube sponsorship beta which means
that we are actually you can sponsor our
YouTube channel directly for $4.99 a
month and those are also supposed to
come up there is a test of that so
hopefully all that stuff will be working
because when it doesn't it's frustrating
and nobody's pleased nobody's happy so
hopefully all that different stuff is
going to be working let's see why don't
we just get right into some of the
normal YouTube live provisions and then
we will just jump into the content so
yeah these are really live I haven't
done it in a while used to do it a lot
it's live so you can actually talk to me
ask questions etc best ways to do that
super chat & stream labs comm slash the
david pakman show if you ask a question
or send a comment via stream labs or
super chat super chat is the dollar sign
at the bottom of the chat window I will
answer it
address it during the live stream very
very exciting people are talking people
love it
number three new members and patrons who
sign up during the show will get shout
outs and thank-yous we are accepting
cryptocurrency now at david pakman.com
slash cryptocurrency and please don't
troll the live chat we have we still
have moderators who have been fully
deputized to ban block and time people
out who are doing annoying stuff in the
live chat just don't do it right we're
all here to have a good time it's not
funny and it's not fun when people troll
the live chat all right let's get right
into the news which is indeed that
robert muller has
subpoenaed Trump Russia documents Trump
Organization documents in the Russia
investigation and I actually don't think
a few people emailed me saying David
you're now vindicated I'll try I'll try
putting myself on camera while we look
at this as well if it gets too laggy
I'll get rid of it I've got an email
from people saying David you're
vindicated because you said earlier this
week when Trump fired Rex Tillerson and
when I've already forgotten which
scandals took place when Trump there was
something else I said something big must
be coming from Muller and this is part
of the pre-emptive distraction campaign
I actually don't know that this is it
some people wrote to me saying David
you're vindicated look at what happened
I actually don't know that this is it
this is big but this didn't just happen
like it this supposedly these documents
were actually subpoenaed from the Trump
Organization some time ago we're just
learning about it now and that's the big
picture that special counsel Robert
Muller has subpoenaed Trump org
documents including documents related to
Russia the sources for the New York
Times which has been doing really pretty
good reporting on this stuff quote - or
name - people briefed on the matter as
the source this is as the New York Times
says the first known instance of Robert
Muller demanding records directly
related to Trump's businesses we've been
speculating all along and it's also been
sort of part of the speculation because
of who Muller has been hiring lawyers
who are experts in financial crimes that
eventually this was going to get to what
you know what specifically we don't know
money-laundering or foreign money
the hush monies paid to stormy Daniels
might be part of it but we knew that
finances were likely going to be a part
of it and this is the first known
instance where Trump business documents
are being requested we don't know the
breadth of the subpoena nor is it clear
why Muller issued it instead of simply
asking for the documents from the
company that's a very interesting thing
because if there was
why would you subpoena if you believe
that you could just get it by asking
right so the fact that there was a
subpoena suggests either that Moeller
had reason to believe the trump
organization was not going to turn the
documents over or they had already asked
for them and the Trump Organization
refused to turn them over as it says
here the subpoena was delivered in
recent weeks that's relevant because it
suggests either that this isn't whatever
Trump was trying to distract from by
firing Tillerson it suggests potentially
that the Tillerson firing was not an act
of preemptive distraction or it suggests
that if it is Trump got a heads-up that
this was going to leak around the time
that it did which is now once again the
timing of this this is a relevant
statement the subpoena is the latest
investigation that the this is the
latest indication that the investigation
is not ending anytime soon you'll
remember you probably remember that
Donald Trump said before the new year
this is going to be over by Thanksgiving
it's gonna be over by Christmas it's
gonna be over by the New Year it's now
March 15th we're halfway through March
we're about a quarter of the way into
2018 and if only now we are getting to
these requests it's not gonna end
anytime soon okay and that I think is
something that we should all be paying
very close attention to because if
anything the indication is that the
investigation is broadening not becoming
more narrow New York Times speculating
that the role that foreign money may
have played in funding Trump's political
activities are going to be explored here
and we see here in recent weeks that
Moeller's investigators have questioned
witnesses including an adviser to the
UAE about the flow of Emirati money to
the United States that is also
particularly interesting to me because
you might remember that or if you
haven't seen my clip today about Jared
Kushner Jared Kushner was involved in
pushing Trump to support a blockade a
financial blockade of Qatar and there
was speculation that it might be related
to the Qatari a group of Qatari
investors opting not to
get involved in financing 666 5th Avenue
a Jared Kushner own building in
Manhattan we also know that that might
have actually been related merely to
emirati influence on Jared Kushner so
there is a theme here when you mentioned
the United Arab Emirates it is not only
looking at the possible flow of money
from the Emirates to the Trump campaign
we also know that Jared Kushner has been
potentially heavily influenced by the
United Arab Emirates let's see what else
we have here we have a quote from Allen
fooder Foss who's the lawyer
representing the Trump Organization
saying since July of 2017 we have
advised the public that the Trump
Organization is fully cooperative with
all investigations including the Special
Counsel and is responding to their
requests the language there is notable
right because as I mentioned you don't
necessarily subpoena documents if you're
Robert Muller if you think you will get
them merely by asking and saying that
they are cooperating and responding to
requests doesn't mean that they are
fulfilling the requests as asked I think
that that is an important thing
Sarah how could be Sanders reiterating
that the president is cooperating with
the inquiry not really meaningful Trump
Organization has said they never had
real estate holdings in Russia but
witnesses recently interviewed by
Moeller have been asked about a possible
deal in Moscow in 2015 a longtime
business associate of Trump's emailed
Michael Cohen at his Trump organization
account claiming he was tied to Putin
and that building Trump Tower Moscow
would help Trump's presidential campaign
yeah no no real surprise is there we've
heard that type of thing before and
we'll see what role what we ultimately
learn about that in the investigation
project didn't ultimately happen but
Trump did sign a non-binding letter of
intent on that this is a very important
paragraph right here that I want to talk
about and what the New York Times
article says is that Moeller could run
afoul of a line that the
resident has warned him not to cross
although it's not clear how much of the
subpoena is related to Trump's business
beyond ties to Russia you'll remember
and this is the key thing in an
interview with Maggie Haberman from the
New York Times who co-authored this
article and another one and by the way
thank you to who we just missed there
was a there was a donation there that
came in from peri Chell which we will we
will get to that we will get to all of
those keep those coming by all means
Donald Trump was asked by Maggie
Haberman and another New York Times
reporter some months ago in July would
it be crossing a red line if Muller
started looking into your personal
finances your family's finances and
Trump said he believed it would so there
is already rampant speculation that this
subpoena might trigger Donald Trump into
firing Robert Muller and you know I wish
I could tell you listen Trump knows he
can't fire Muller it would just be
politically untenable or a Trump has the
audacity maybe to fire Muller
I really can't I really can't I don't
know where Donald Trump's head is on
that and at this point I really can't
say I think it is within the realm of
possibility that Donald Trump would fire
Mahler still at this time we will have
to wait and see and whether this will
sort of create a pretext for that I
don't really know I don't really know
but I am very very interested in seeing
let's get to some of the Super chats and
questions that have been coming in Ryan
Couture has sent a $2 Super chat asking
when we take calls on Wednesday
typically 1:15 p.m. Eastern
okay typically 1:15 p.m. Eastern is when
we take live calls on Wednesday we do
get the interest level in the live calls
has been completely off the charts so I
apologize in advance that we can't get
to every call we take somewhere between
6 and 12 calls typically and we usually
receive in the neighborhood of 40 or so
so we just be literally unless we do the
so as calls which I know people
generally don't want we we can't get to
everybody so I apologize in advance for
that Ryan but 1:15 p.m. Eastern and the
number is 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 you can also
leave a voicemail at two one nine to
david p that's another option perry
chell has left a 10 British Pound super
chat or stream lapse contribution no
super chat yes thank you very much no
question comment and Sarah Dobson has
left a British Pound 99 super chat
asking what's the hardest part about
making the show you know the hardest
part is just that we're a small
organization and everybody's doing 10
things
everybody's doing 10 things so every
single day we're dealing with
advertisers we're dealing with guests
we're dealing with production we're
dealing with research we're dealing with
booking guests from both the interview
prep and logistical side I'm running the
business aspects of the show we've got
you know producer Pat who's interfacing
with the guests and preparing every
single day for all the stuff that's up
on the screen and we've got producer
Noah who's dealing with advertisers and
producing long-form pieces and the
critical thinking miniseries and as soon
as it's over we're basically starting
the entire thing over again and that
actually relates to the degree to which
everybody is doing many things relates
to what hopefully will be a very
exciting upcoming announcement on the
program and we have as many of you know
there have been 2017 was a crazy year
things stabilized a little bit in 2018
part of it has been well part of it has
been because of patreon right so patreon
has been a really really big thing there
that that's a place where we have over
2,000 patrons currently that's led to a
lot of exciting projects the
critical-thinking miniseries for example
and I'll have some announcements soon
actually to make about the production of
the program let's get to I wonder if I
can even show you the super chats as
they come in here
that's not that's not the best I'm not
I'm not loving the way that's looking
next super chat is from clarf one two
three four who sent to Australian
dollars asking have I ever been offered
a job on a news network no I haven't I
don't know that I'm just I don't know
that I'm the right guy for like
corporate media and two years ago if you
had asked me what's like my dream end
game for the show I would have said
something like getting hired by
corporate media and over the last two
years things have changed so drastically
on the program the David Pakman show has
grown so much and in talking to my
friends and more colleagues than close
friends who are contributors on
corporate media or our hosts on
corporate media I don't know that it's
for me I don't I mean that's definitely
no longer the dream the dream is
actually just to keep growing the David
Pakman show and I've sort of renewed my
commitment to it because the oversight
the editorial oversight and people are
telling you what is okay and what's not
okay and getting notes from management I
will deal with the hate mail from the
audience because ultimately I decide
what goes on the show and what doesn't
go on the show and that is a level of
control that I just could never have
could never have on corporate media and
so it's really not the goal anymore it
was the goal at one point and it's not
anymore so I've not been offered a job
on a news network and at this point my
focus really is on growing independent
media maintaining total control over the
show nobody can tell me what stories to
do what stories not to do we have total
control over our agreements with
advertisers which I don't even work on
anymore that's another thing that that
we're doing that I think is great which
is that now that we have someone in
producer Noah Ferguson who's working
with our advertisers I effectively do
not speak to our advertisers with rare
occasions where they might have some
kind of question that I get pulled in on
answering I don't negotiate with the
advertisers I don't
I basically we basically have separation
and I think that's a really good thing
usually at organizations as small as we
are I'd be doing everything and I would
be directly involved in that
and there we have setup we've been lucky
enough to be able to set up a system
where that's not the case so that's
that's a really good thing
Ronald Finkley has sent a $2 super chat
with no question or comment very very
much appreciate that as well
and also over on stream labs.com / the
david pakman show David's mom has sent a
$3 and 90 cent stream Labs contribution
saying hi honey would love to see you
engage in more debates you're extremely
talented at debating and should utilize
this skill more two reasons I can tell
you that's not my mom number one my mom
speaks to me in Spanish and number two
my mom when she speaks English when she
writes English she doesn't use British
Spelling's so in case anybody thought
that was my mom it's not Jane a has sent
a for dollar and 99 cents super chat
asking if Muller finds dirt now will
they move to impeach what should we
expect I think that there is not going
to be impeachment of Donald Trump I
think that even if Robert Mulder finds
dirt at this point you will more likely
see particularly with Republicans
controlling the House and Senate you are
more likely to see charges filed against
Trump which is legally a question mark
still and a sort of constitutional
crisis as to the constitutionality of
charging a sitting president I think
that that is the more likely scenario I
just don't think you're going to see the
current status quo of
republican-controlled House and Senate
do that 2018 election though and yet
another reason why it is super super
important for everybody to vote and I've
been talking about that I'm worried I am
genuinely worried about low voter
turnout in the 2018 midterms even though
we've had a great growth in activism
from as a result of Donald Trump's
presidency I'm worried that it's going
to be another pathetic turnout by the
left at but not that the Wrights turnout
is anything to write home about but I
care about turn
from the left and that it might not go
that well so I'm worried about that
Grover Capri --ls has sent a five-dollar
super chat asking do you think that it's
possible to implement Bernie's ideas in
South America David don't give up I was
inspired to run for president in a South
American country alright Grover jeez I
don't know exactly what Grover is
talking about but it's a very very
interesting question you know South
America's politics are interesting they
are very very different than North
American politics I'm from Argentina as
many of you know and I follow our gen
Tinian politics pretty closely
although and Venezuelan politics but
beyond that I'm certainly no Latin
American political expert Colombian
politics maybe would be would be third
after that I think that the people of
South America are already much more open
to the ideas of social democracy of
someone like Bernie Sanders the problem
that South America has is that there are
a lot of people whose rhetoric a lot of
elected officials and candidates in
South America Latin America whose
rhetoric is very left populist sounding
sort of like Bernie but in
implementation
they are authoritarian total
authoritarian totally authoritarian what
we've seen in Venezuela with Hugo Chavez
followed by Nicolas Maduro as an example
of that I know there's a sort of
Leninist string of the left that is not
that's not my thing I want nothing to do
with that but there is this Leninist
string on the left that tries to paint
Venezuelan leadership both shabbos and
Maduro as this just sort of bastion of
true leftism and it's it's an
authoritarian implementation of populist
rhetoric and I've been pretty clear
about that all along and my views on
that are they are what they are not
everybody likes them now we have an
attempt at really mimicking my mom
through a stream lapse contribution a
user going by La MaMa Dada beat or
David's mom has made a $3 90 cent
contribution saying hola hijo por que no
hacer math devatas tiene mucho talento
para ser
Familia shawty I can tell you this is
also not my mom because my mom would
write to me in Argentinean Spanish she
would say Dennis muchacha Lindo rather
than tienes mucha talento so sadly
foiled again oil again that is
definitely not my mom in any way shape
or form okay let me catch you up on a
couple things that are going on and
let's see if I can actually pull these
up and show you what is going on here I
want to talk a little bit about the
critical thinking miniseries so let me
see if I can pull that up and we can
actually look at it together I really
like that now I'm able to share my
browser
during these things so the critical
thinking miniseries that is funded by
the patreon contributors that we
garnered I think it was a month and a
half ago or something like that that is
now that is now up the first half of it
roughly is up now there's a very very
cool thing which is that for patrons
rather than having to wait for each
individual clip to publish they have the
first half of it already up and as you
can see here it was pre released for
patrons and part two will be released
soon so this is a good reason to either
become a patron or a member because both
patrons and members were given access to
that first entire half of the critical
thinking miniseries upfront that is a
really really great thing and we've all
been working on that as a team and it's
extraordinary and you can get instant
access to that that long form video by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can also become a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership i voted 17 has ended ok so I
voted 17 was a long time 2017 coupon
code for membership it's over and now
the new coupon code if you want to save
40% is vote soon 18 okay so you can use
that coupon code sign up for a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and you will get access to
that long form critic
thinking miniseries we're also doing
free bumper stickers okay so right now
anybody who signs up for a yearly
membership on our website and to do that
you got to switch over to yearly right
people some sometimes confused about
this not monthly yearly membership pick
the yearly membership of your choice
when you hit the signup button you will
be taken to this second screen and if
you enter the coupon code vote soon 18
when you hit the signup button and go to
the next page your membership will be
discounted 40% and when that happens you
still can qualify for the free bumper
sticker and all you need to do to get
that is email me respond to your new
member email say David I want the black
bumper sticker David I want the white
bumper sticker here's my address and
it's a beautiful thing and people
placing bumper stickers all over the
country over Infowars Alex Jones bumper
stickers people doing very very creative
and great things and on that note I want
to thank James Ulrich James Ulrich has
signed up for membership just what we've
been chatting here and I really
appreciate that really appreciate
everybody who has signed up and as many
of you know listen I don't need to
repeat it 2017 was tough 2017 was very
very tough and we have started to
started to recover nameless King has
made a $5 stream lapse contribution
saying hey David how come you never
covered the 300,000 jobs created last
month that Trump bragged about is the
Republican tax cut responsible for the
massive amount of jobs created love your
show I thought we did I mean we covered
that pretty regularly regularly if we
didn't cover that my guess is that it's
because of the timing we had a couple
days off in February but I cover that
and we go you know job creation is not
linked to any one piece of economic
policy and to the extent that Donald
Trump does economic policy
we will address how that relates to job
creation but certainly if the
implication is and I'm not saying that
it is if the implication is that I won't
cover economic news under Trump when
it's good by no means I've talked about
this the stock market that has run up
I've talked about who that's good for
and who that's not good for it's not
good for everybody for sure and you know
I covered good and bad economic news
under President Obama and that's that's
what we do on the show there's no I
don't know if there was anything else
sort of implicit in that question
okay I want to tell you about an
upcoming interview that I think you're
gonna really like and the reason that I
think you're going to really like it is
it's actually already been filmed and it
is with an exorcist okay we are going to
be running this interview next week I
interviewed a woman who claims to be a
real Exorcist and that when I say a real
Exorcist I don't mean that I believe in
exorcism what I mean is that they claim
to be a real Exorcist and I don't even
want to say too much about it but I
think you're going to really like it
it's it's gonna be a doozy that's for
sure
okay Jerry Hickel has sent a five-dollar
super chat saying keep it up David the
show keeps getting better
well thank you Jerry I really appreciate
that very very much Chaka Barry has sent
a five-dollar super chat will you debate
Kyle kolinsky over Russia like on a
plane while we are flying over Russia
I'd be willing to do that not I wouldn't
fly Aeroflot but I'd be willing to
debate Kyle kolinsky while flying over
Russia have you talked to Kyle about his
opinion no Kyle and I here's what I
think sometimes people don't get and why
should you right so I'm gonna tell you
sort of about how this works almost
everybody I talked to on a semi-regular
basis who have has a show Sam cedar
Ferren and the behind-the-scenes people
at Ring of Fire
Kyle kolinsky from secular talk not so
much Dave Rubin anymore as many of you
know but we used to talk
who else Jen briny talked to Genk and
Steve and Erin from The Young Turks at
least once or twice a year we do not
talk about politics we I think for all
of us we basically get enough politics
doing the shows and so we talk about how
is the monetizing the monetization
hitting you how is house membership
what's going on on patreon did I think I
just did something very weird with my
hair there I'm growing it out by the way
but more on that later we basically
don't talk about politics so I know that
Kyle is somewhat skeptical on the Russia
issue at this point you know I here's my
thing I don't know what there is to
debate like we can debate basically
there there are things we know and there
are things we don't yet know and we will
not know until the investigation Robert
Moeller's investigation gets closer to
or finishes and we see what charges are
filed so there's really nothing to
debate about the evidence because it's
limited right now because it's an
ongoing investigation and
circumstantially there's stuff going on
so really it would be a debate over our
opinions as to how important the issue
of Russia is and how much different
parties should focus on it so it doesn't
strike me like it would be an
interesting debate I know a lot of
people say David debate Kyle about
Russia I think it would be pretty boring
because I would agree with him that I
think that Democrats need a platform and
they need to get out the vote and they
need to run progressive candidates where
those can win they need to run more
moderate Democratic candidates when
there's an opportunity to use that to
win a Republican seat I think generally
we would agree that Democrats aren't
gonna win elections on the Russia issue
and we should I I assume he agrees with
letting the investigation run its course
so I don't think it would be as
interesting as people think it would be
yeah that's kind of my thought about
that real life Joe Lee has sent a $5 a
super chat hey David I'm wondering if
you recognize the name in the username I
have and if so if you've read that book
in your original language or in French
no I actually don't
so I'm guessing it's a Spanish book with
a character named Jolie what is that
I'm not even finding anything I don't
know where that's from are they
referring to the the author Mart Martine
Jolie or maybe it's a French book that I
might have read in Spanish I don't even
know is it Maurice Jolie who wrote Oh
Maurice Jolie a French publicist and
lawyer known for his political satire
titled dialogue between Machiavelli and
Montesquieu or the politic of
Machiavelli no I have not read it I've
not read it I've not read really any any
uh I've not read it I don't know what
else I can say I've not not not
something I'm familiar with and Chaka
Barry following up with a $2.00 super
Chet thank you for pronouncing my name
correctly you know sometimes people say
to me that they're surprised I
pronounced the name correctly it happens
with guests a lot and I'll look at the
name and I'll say I don't know how
anyone could pronounce it a different
way I mean certainly Barry I'm familiar
with I can't imagine how else that would
be pronounced and even Chaka like when I
look at it it just it doesn't look like
che Rocca it doesn't look like sharika I
just don't even know how someone else
would would pronounce that but my
pleasure my pleasure okay let's see
let's go through I don't I want to do
this thing where I go through the
regular chat window let's see if I can
even put it up on the screen we will go
let's see if I can move I'll move over
here and how can I do this let me figure
out the best way to do this it's like so
people can see what I'm looking at I
don't want to just do super chat okay I
think this is this is as good as
anything else here we go okay let's see
what else is here is David on Joe
Rogan's okay where where's David's Jew
gold so that could could possibly be
worthy of AB and Marta Mario asking oh
and it looks like that person
immediately
not banned by Daniel Smeltzer nice one
Daniel very very nice
Mario asking art at a cantina by Adele
mundial asking whether Argentina is
going to the World Cup
yes Argentina's going to the World Cup
and I'm very much looking forward to it
is David a Jew yes David is a Jew and
when Beltran asking is David on Joe
Rogan's radar I am I know for a fact now
that I am on the radar of Joe Rogan's
producer because we exchanged emails and
I think that he kind of blew me off he
said something along the lines of I will
let Joe know that we have made contact
which is very very different than I'm
sure Joe's going to be interested in
talking to you but I I would love to be
on the Joe Rogan program not as some
people suggest that I do to go and set
him straight or anything like that I
think that there's a conversation I
would like to have with him about
misconceptions about the left and about
progressivism and social justice
warriors and issues of free speech I'd
be super interested in being on Joe
Rogan's program I you know I would say
tweet to him and tell him to have me on
but I've heard that he doesn't really
like that
so I don't know I mean if somebody can
help me get on then by all means help me
get on but I don't know what the method
would be see what else we've got here
Jason Pfister saying David is very manly
all right very good what else do we have
here debate sean hannity debate kyle
kolinsky david gets 5 o'clock shadow by
1 p.m. because he's so manly they're
very very very true and that's a good
one mr. t800 I'm not currently able to
send super chat someone wants to donate
and ask my question a while ago you
talked about doing investigative
journalism is that still on your roadmap
yeah I mean we've been doing
investigative long-form pieces which I
know is not the same as going out and
doing investigative pieces were hoping
hopefully working out up to that all
right hopefully working up to that
Anthony Hamlin saying get a jew-fro like
me yeah I've sort of decided that I'm
going to grow out my hair and I think
the idea will be just to keep getting
like a longer and longer
this and then like kind of trim it down
around the edges and keep it going and
we'll see what it looks like I've never
had long hair and I think it's time to
do it why not right let's see what else
we've got here
no more dave rubin why yeah I mean I I
don't really know that the full scope of
this I've mentioned I think I might have
had a falling-out with Dave Rubin after
the interview I did where I asked him
what I thought were reasonably tough and
totally fair questions I don't know that
he liked how I handled that interview
and I we haven't spoken much we had it
we exchanged one set of text messages
about Roger Vere who we both interviewed
the Bitcoin cash guy and I don't know if
Ruben is upset with me or not I'm not
I'm not really sure I saw your debate
with destiny he got destroyed well done
I never did a debate with destiny I had
destiny on and we talked about issues on
the left and right but I certainly
didn't debate him never mind destroy him
so maybe maybe you're thinking of
something else there what other comments
do we have here do I have to be a member
to donate asks more of no you can use
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window you can go to stream laughs
comm slash the david pakman show both of
those work you do not have to be a
member to donate a couple other super
chats coming in Jerry Hickel says you
got my last name wrong it's Jerry hike
Oh Jerry Heikal Jerry Heikal not Jerry
Hickel I stand corrected and I apologize
I do apologize and I do want to thank
Austin Alan Austin Alan has signed up
for membership using the coupon code
vote soon 18 and as I mentioned we've
got a coupon code which is available to
anybody who wants it you simply go to
david pakman.com slash membership when
you get to david pakman.com slash
membership i should really zoom this out
so people can see it a little bit better
yeah there we go when you go to david
pakman.com slash membership you got to
switch to yearly okay if you want a free
bumper sticker once you do that you
the red sign up button I don't know why
everything is jittering like that maybe
I should not be zooming it in you hit
the red sign-up button on the second
page of the sign up you type in the
coupon code vote soon 18 which of course
I am blocking because of where there we
go and once you type in vote soon 18 and
hit sign up your any membership will get
discounted to only to a 40% discount
after you do that simply write to me and
say hey David I want to claim my free
bumper sticker
send me your address I will get you a
free david pakman show bumper-sticker
and jerry following up with just one
more Super chat today Jerry Heikal no
apologies needed everyone gets it wrong
well thanks I appreciate that you're not
mad
Matthew Campos sent a five-dollar super
chat asking what do you think of Messi
and de baile not being able to play
together on the national team thoughts
on president Macri visiting Russia
during the World Cup yeah I Argentina
just regularly has problems with their
national team there their World Cup team
lineup and it's pretty damn depressing
and I'm trying not to even think about
it too much
I think it's fine for the President of
Argentina to go to Russia during the
World Cup I don't love Messi's cozy
relationship with Russia bigger picture
right World Cup or not I'm kind of less
concerned with Dan yo has sent a $5
Super chat what are your thoughts on the
crooked media guys well partisan media
will partisan media where outlets are
overtly supporting candidates become
more common I have no clue what crooked
media is I don't know what crooked media
is let's uh let's check it out why don't
we crooked media home what do we have
here Trump's message of hope and
inclusion what the hell is this sign up
taking the gavel from Paul Ryan's hand I
have no clue what this is I just don't
know what this is let's look at their
team who is part of their team a sane
conversation about politics Twitter is a
great place to
lose your mind a no-bullshit
conversation about politics Jon Favreau
was Obama's head speechwriter John
Lovett is a straight shooter
speechwriter for Hillary all right so
it's like a left-wing thing Tommy Vietor
worked for Obama Dan Pfeiffer that's an
Obama guy anamarie Cox I know she's
left-wing DeRay McKesson not sure who
that is IRA Madison the third Jason
Kander listen I don't know anything
about this but I don't really have a
problem with media openly supporting
candidates we just want to make sure we
know what we're dealing with we want to
be able to distinguish between news and
opinion programming sort of period right
I mean that that that's what I care
about I have no problem with partisan
media what I do have a problem with is
is propaganda and deliberate fake news
that's what I think is really
destructive mário Caetano have sent a $5
Super chat which I really very much
appreciate no question or comment but I
really do appreciate that thank you very
much that is really really important
really great to do the support to see
the support when we do the live streams
and I'm going to try to recommit too
well to the live streams I genuinely
apologize that I've not had the time to
do them and particularly now that we do
have YouTube sponsorship so for I know
there are people who still have never
seen this and the reason is it's a beta
thing that YouTube is testing out so for
example like when I look I always see it
it's this sponsor button and for the
most part it also shows up when you look
at an individual video so like if I open
up this video
Youmans make sure it's muted I always
see the sponsor button and what that
allows you to do is for $4.99 a month
you get extra content early release
content and something that's very cool
is that our sponsors also when they
participate in the chat they have an
official David Pakman sponsor logo that
appears so they
are distinguished in a way when they
participate in live stream chat so that
is an extra thing an extra reason for
people to sign up for the YouTube
sponsorship and you know I think YouTube
is kind of testing it and if it doesn't
do well they may do away with
sponsorship altogether my goal would be
to try to get 1% of our YouTube audience
to become sponsors right so we've got
about four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers if we could get 1%
that'd be forty five hundred sponsors
even half of one percent twenty two
hundred and fifty sponsors at $4.99 a
month the majority of which goes to us
that is a really big deal
so check that out Troy machan Roy has
sent a five Canadian dollar super chat
asking have you seen the underscore
Donald subreddit if so should it be
removed I've seen it I will often check
the Donald subreddit when I want to see
what is the committed Trumpets response
to something in the news I will go and
look at the Donald subreddit sometimes
and I don't know whether it should be
removed I mean I'm pretty wide open on
free speech I think short of inciting
violence we should allow content to stay
the problem is that you can make the
case that the Donalds subreddit incites
violence and on that basis I think it
would be legitimate for reddit to shut
it down it would also be legitimate for
ready to shut it down on the basis of it
just violates our policy on hateful
content but that does open up sort of a
possible Pandora's box
Eric quinones has sent a $2 super chat
saying simply great job well thanks Eric
appreciate that appreciate the support
and that's gonna do it for me today I
got to sort of work back up to the live
streams because it it requires stamina
and I want to thank everybody who joined
me and I'm gonna try to get back to it
and and do more live streams and before
I go I do want to get to Bobby Fox's ten
British pound super chat who said does
it worry you that people live in their
own political bubbles with recommended
features and new services the Wright has
done this for years but the left is
falling into the trappings of it I have
been talking about this for a while this
is the problem of filter
filter bubbles and really finely tuned
social-media algorithms make it super
easy and convenient never to see
dissenting or alternative views and I do
worry about it it's a disaster and we've
got to do what we can to get people to
break breakthrough and out of those and
a lot of that means telling people I
understand that your views lend
themselves to these media outlets would
you be willing to check out what this
show or this outlet said and I don't
know of any way to do it on a mass scale
I really don't Bobby so I'm very
concerned about it and depressed about
it all right I will talk to you soon
thanks thanks for watching my first live
stream in a while